so the fda has now authorized for
emergency use
while they are still evaluating uh a
full approval of the pfizer covid19
vaccine
the pfizer coveted shot has been
approved under emergency use for 12 to
15 year olds
remember that uh jnj and moderna
shots currently approved 18 plus pfizer
was already 16 plus
now it is 12 plus this is
a great bit of news because there are 17
million
12 to 15 year olds in the united states
that represents about
five six percent of the total population
and that is a significant chunk
particularly when we think about
students being back in school many
already
and almost a certainty that they will be
going back to school in person in the
fall
being able to uh make eligible
an additional five or six percent of the
total population is a really great thing
uh this has been widely tested uh we
know that
the vaccine is uh essentially 100
effective at preventing serious disease
and death in 12 to 15 year olds
it triggers a robust antibody response
and there's a recent survey from the
kaiser family foundation's vaccine
monitor
which found that many parents even those
who have themselves been vaccinated
are reluctant to vaccinate their
adolescent kids sort of in that 12 to 16
12 to 17 range it's really important
that that happens
for several reasons not the least of
which is that
going back to school without vaccinated
kids
just doesn't pass the sniff test it just
doesn't make logical sense
and we are expecting vaccination for 12
to 15 year olds to start
this week appointments at least in some
states already being open to 12 to 15
year olds as soon as uh as soon as
tomorrow as soon as friday
and um we are going to see uh likely as
we saw
with the adult vaccination uh an initial
surge
and then probably a tapering off and
that's fine just
you know every time we get new
eligibility let's get as many people as
we can vaccinated and then over the
summer
as schools say in order to come back on
campus you're going to need a vaccine
you're going to see more and more people
in that age range go and get that
vaccine
states counties and school districts
around the country
per the new york times are trying to
figure out the most reassuring
way to reach those younger adolescents
as well as their parents
in most states parents have to consent
to 12 to 15 year olds being vaccinated
um and so it will be not just the 12 to
15 year olds who need to want to get the
shot
it will also have to be the parents
which which makes sense
uh in most cases and there are plans to
offer the vaccines not only in schools
but also at pediatricians offices
day camps parks beaches and we're
increasingly hearing about uh
even some restaurants in some cases
getting involved
in the vaccine effort so you know
there's no question
i've been seeing on facebook anecdotally
people saying my kid is not getting any
shot they're not getting anything
experimental
there will be that there is that in
every single group
that's going to decline as 12 to 15 year
olds
start to get vaccinated and
overwhelmingly
start not to get the virus because the
vaccine works so well
certainly um schools requiring vaccines
for in-person attendance
are going to further increase the number
of parents who will say well i wasn't
big on it but
i've got to get these kids out of the
house i mean quite frankly it's sort of
a silly thing to say
to think about it in those terms but
that is going to be a factor as well
and uh there are going to be all sorts
of mobile vaccination
initiatives and uh plans
to just make it as easy as possible for
12 to 15 year olds to get
vaccinated so i continue to say
that by memorial day a lot of these
numbers are going to look significantly
better we expected them to start looking
better in mid-may and they are
we just went over that cases are now
down 84 percent
deaths are now down 81 percent and
there is still you know i think there's
a couple things going on there's still a
lot of doom and gloomers
who are only focusing on the negatives
and there
are negatives 650 deaths a day while
down 81
from the peak is still a lot but in the
more vaccinated states you are starting
to see the daily deaths get down to
and even below the number of daily
deaths you typically see in a flu season
that is very good news and there is no
question at this point that we are able
to vaccinate our way out of this so
if you have kids in the 12 to 15 age
range
i would love to hear from you how are
you thinking of
this new emergency use approval on 12 to
15
if you are vaccinated but you don't plan
to have your kids get the vaccine
let me know why i'd be curious to hear
from you and we'll have more about the
vaccination effort on the show's
instagram page
make sure you're following us there at
david pakman show and make sure you're
following me on instagram as well at
david.pakman we'll take a quick break
we will talk about the latest covid lab
leak conspiracies dr
fauci was confronted by rand paul or
maybe rand paul was confronted by dr
fauci i don't know exactly
we'll have to look at the video and
decide for ourselves that'll be after
this short break and much more upcoming
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman